okay if someone came to me and said
David did you rape this woman I would
say I would never rape anyone the
characteristics of the person wouldn't
be a factor if they were attractive if
they weren't attractive it wouldn't make
a difference if they were male or female
it wouldn't make a difference
I just don't rape anybody and that would
be my focus Donald Trump however has
previously talked about the
attractiveness or the type of woman when
he has denied various rape and sexual
assault allegations and there are many
of those and he's done it again Donald
Trump gave an interview to the hill
yesterday including two cigar and jetty
who interviewed me last week on the hill
TV and Donald Trump has denied the
allegation from eg Carol saying she's
not my type with all due respect an
indication that as far as Donald Trump
is concerned this is not an attractive
enough woman for Donald Trump to
consider raping take a look at the exact
quote from Donald Trump I'll say it with
great respect number one she's not my
type
number two it never happened it never
happened okay totally lying I don't know
anything about her I know nothing about
this woman I know nothing about her she
is it's just a terrible thing that
people can make statements like that I
say this with respect she's not my type
is code for she's not attractive enough
for me to want to sexually assault her
or to rape her but of course her
appearance and her type should make no
difference to someone who doesn't
sexually assault or rape women the right
answer here is I didn't rape her because
I've never raped anyone
and I would never rape anyone or
sexually assault anyone or use physical
force to get anyone in a situation like
the one that is described if you're
asked if you raped someone and you say
no she's not my type that suggests
there's a type you would be willing to
rape or sexually assault he's not
denying that if she were his type
he might have or would have sexually
assaulted her or raped her and remember
Trump is accused of raping his first
wife there are under
both documents from the divorce
proceedings I believe it is there may be
some other kind of court proceeding
about this Trump also by saying she's
not my type is continuing this idea that
rape is a sexual act when it's a very
violent act in reality it's the
exercising of power over someone else
but that's probably a few levels too
deep for this conversation or at least
any conversation involving Donald Trump
and for everyone talking about another
lying woman lying about Trump raping her
sexually assaulting her 16 allegations
of sexual assault have not taken Donald
Trump down so far he even got himself
elected after the grabbing by the [ __ ]
recording would anyone be dumb enough to
think that if they add their name and
make themselves number 17 or number 18
on the list of people that Donald Trump
allegedly sexually assaulted would
anyone really at this point be dumb
enough to think that that's gonna pull
Donald Trump from office which gets us
to the idea that these women are
motivated by what right I mean becoming
rich and famous by saying that you were
raped because rape victims end up
leading such charmed lives she's getting
death threats from trumpets which I'll
talk about next why do you think so many
rapes go unreported
so these ignorant trumpets who come up
with just ridiculous bogus defense after
ridiculous bogus defense they seem to
have no understanding whatsoever of just
basic human psychology and live in a
complete and total bubble about how rape
accusers are treated in society
particularly when they say that the
person that accused them is a prominent
Republican politician we've seen that
we've got a number of examples of how
that goes it doesn't lead to a
particularly thrilling and exciting
charmed life and the idea that that
would be the motivation aside from not
being based in fact in terms of basic
motivations there's no drama
demonstrable proof that that's actually
how it works out one of today's sponsors
is impeach the card slap game
you cannot slap Donald Trump in real
life but you can slap him in this
hilarious fast-paced two-player card
game and you can get it for ten percent
off when you go to David
mancom slash impeach and use the coupon
code pakman show at checkout all one
word awesome for parties when you're
having a few drinks I've been playing it
with some friends of mine currently has
a 5 out of 5 star rating on Amazon and
it combines clever satire about the
Trump administration with really funny
high-quality cartoon artwork all in a
really lively card game that's easy to
learn but it stays interesting every
time you play it because of how
well-designed it is and really how much
thought went into the humor and the
political commentary the game covers a
ton of themes global warming Russian
collusion tax cuts for the wealthy
impeach the card slap game is perfect if
you're looking for something fun and
casual to do with your politically
minded friends or family members you
might even learn something new about the
Trump administration while you're
playing the game it's a perfect gift for
anyone who has a sense of humor about
Trump or get it for yourself and have a
really fun and witty game to play when
people come over you can even play it
tournament style get impeach the cards
slap game by going to david pakman.com
slash impeach and get 10% off when you
use the coupon code pakman show at
checkout all one word